bonjour c'est le journal de la rédaction
à retenir dans l'actualité de ce
vendredi 31 octobre le CIDFF des
Yvelines pour l'égalité professionnelle
homme-femme le Centre d'Information des
droits des femmes et des familles vient
de réaliser trois clips de
sensibilisation
ils ont profité à des vacances de la
Toussaint pour passer leur BAFA leur
brevet d'aptitude aux fonctions
d'animateur cela s'est déroulé à Voisins
le bretonneux nous avons voulu savoir
comment s'obtenir ce diplôme et qu'elle
en était le contenu et puis le théâtre
de 50 ans en Yvelines un nouveau
directeur il prendra ses fonctions en
janvier à 2015 Lionel massetta actuelle
directeur de Londres de Vélizy et puis
nous reviendrons également sur
l'essentiel de la semaine écoulée
mais nous débarons tout d'abord pardon
par cet appel lancé par les gendarmes du
Sud des Yvelines depuis ce jeudi 16h ils
sont à la recherche de Pierre Ardouin 90
ans mystérieusement disparu après avoir
quitté en voiture son domicile de Senlis
pour aller prendre de l'essence à
quelques kilomètres au
Mesnil-Saint-Denis les gendarmes ont
engagé d'importants moyens de recherche
pour tenter de retrouver sa voiture Nike
verte si vous voyez cette automobiliste
correspond un automobiliste pardon
correspondant à sa description vous
pouvez contacter la gendarmerie des
Yvelines aux 01 39 67 50 15 ou bien tout
simplement composer le 17
le CIDFF des Yvelines vient de lancer
une campagne de sensibilisation un
groupe de femmes de 50 ans en Yvelines a
réalisé trois vidéos de promotion de
l'égalité professionnelle femme homme et
je vous propose de regarder un de ses
clips on en parle ensuite avec Valérie
Caneta pilote du projet
une femme et un homme ont la même
formation le même diplôme les mêmes
compétences quel est votre parcours
professionnel pouvez-vous argumenter vos
compétences quels sont vos projets pour
ce poste avez-vous des enfants vous avez
des enfants vous envisagez d'avoir des
enfants une maternité peut poser un
problème de personnes et dans
l'entreprise être mère peut poser un
problème dans un parcours professionnel
une femme et un homme ont la même
formation le même diplôme les mêmes
compétences quel est votre parcours
professionnel pouvez-vous argumenter vos
compétences quelles sont vos projets
pour ce poste est-ce que vous êtes marié
quel est votre situation familiale
est-ce que votre femme travaille
envisagez-vous de prendre un congé
paternité
la blague je rêve c'est pour dans 30 ans
n'importe quoi il ne demande jamais ça
non mais je rêve pas un homme bah
pourquoi
oui je suis femme oui je suis même oui
je suis compétente et professionnelle
vivement l'égalité
le CIDFF le centre des droits des femmes
et des familles vient donc de lancer
vous venez le voir un nouvel outil de
promotion de l'égalité professionnelle
la femme homme donc à travers trois
vidéos ces vidéos traitent des
inégalités professionnelles pouvaient
pouvant être rencontré lors d'entretien
d'embauche de l'exercice d'un poste à
responsabilité ou encore d'une réunion
de travail et pour en parler avec nous
par téléphone nous avons Valérie Caneta
bonjour
vous êtes conseiller en poids aussi et
des FF et des Yvelines vous êtes pilote
de l'opération alors d'abord pourquoi
avoir lancé cette action
alors belle action en fait ce sont de
toute façon des thèmes récurrents
importants pour le CIDFF
pour cela on souhaitait sensibiliser au
préjugés et aux stéréotypes qui conduit
souvent à des comportements sexistes et
puis c'était aussi la feuille une façon
de d'élargir les choix professionnels et
d'accompagner les femmes victimes
d'inégalités professionnelles comment
s'est mis en place une mise en place
cette opération les témoignages qu'on
entend dans ces clips dans ces vidéos
pardon sont des vrais témoignages
recueillis alors voilà rien n'a été
inventé nous avons d'abord animé trois
conférences débats pour pour introduire
le sujet et puis après nous avons
demandé aux femmes de témoigner de
réfléchir de penser les situations
autrement et ce sont en fait toutes les
phrases tout ce qu'elles ont dit tout
leur ressentis tout leur vécu qui mis
bout à bout avec la participation donc
d'Anise Maurice et de Catherine
Bocquillon du collectif case qui ont
monté les spots
que nous avons créé c'est ces scénarii
et on est parti comme ça justement qui
sont ces femmes qui ont raconté de leur
expérience sont des femmes forcément
toutes salariés alors non elles ont été
salariés où elles le sont encore et ce
sont des femmes qui s'adressent au cidfs
de façon spontanée qui viennent nous
voir donc dans le cadre de des actions
que l'on peut mener mais aussi des
entretiens individuels quand elles ont
des interrogations par rapport à leurs
recherches d'emploi par rapport à leur
déroulement de carrière par rapport aux
difficultés qu'elles rencontres sur le
plan professionnel quand elles veulent
faire évoluer aussi leur vie
professionnelle donc ce sont des
personnes qui viennent nous rencontrer
pour qui on avec lesquels on fait un
petit bout de chemin avec lesquels on
fait l'accompagnement en fonction de
leurs besoins et donc avec cette action
je leur ai proposé à certaines d'entre
elles je leur ai proposé de participer
vraiment sur la base du bénévolat oui
voilà et elles ont elles ont dit oui
tout de suite elles ont dit oui celles
qui ont participé on dit oui tout de
suite oui oui tout à fait et alors
pourquoi ces trois thèmes en particulier
l'entretien d'embauche l'exercice d'un
poste à responsabilité et la réunion de
travail parce que c'est vraiment ce qui
est ressorti le plus fréquemment des
entretiens que vous avez avec ces femmes
exactement en fait c'était vraiment les
trois
j'allais dire les trois grands sujets
les trois grandes
occasion en fait dans lesquelles elles
ont ressenti le plus les injustices
professionnels des inégalités et donc on
les a
rassemblés sur ces trois thèmes là on
aurait pu faire d'autres choses
donc c'est pour ça que c'est important
important d'en parler important de de
diffuser et puis surtout de leur dire
aussi que voilà ils sont pas toutes
seules il y a souvent quand on est
victime d'une injustice on a
l'impression il y a un repli sur soi qui
se fait parce qu'on a l'impression que
ça n'arrive qu'à nous et en fait non pas
du tout elles sont nombreuses il y a il
y a des femmes qui veulent faire avancer
ça il y a des hommes aussi ça aussi il
faut le dire et on peut rien faire sans
les hommes non plus on peut pas non plus
avancer sans que la volonté elle soit
vraiment collective mais vrai c'est vrai
qu'il y a encore du travail à faire
c'est vrai et ces clips de promotion
alors ils vont être diffusés largement
vous savez où
utiliser largement j'espère alors en
fait le but au départ c'était quand même
que ce soit un outil dans des
interventions futures soit par nos
partenaires de l'insertion mais aussi
ben voilà si que ça fasse boule de neige
que les gens en parlent et puis pourquoi
pas aussi dans les entreprises dans le
recrutement dans
peu importe il faut juste que l'on en
parle quoi il faut effectivement ça
c'est ce que je souhaite vraiment
vraiment effectivement il faut il faut
en parler merci beaucoup Valérie le
Canada d'avoir répondu à nos questions
merci beaucoup et je rappelle donc au
revoir je rappelle que le CDF des
Yvelines on vient de lancer un outil de
promotion pour l'égalité professionnelle
femme homme à travers des clips vidéos
avec une vidéo de promotion allez un
tout autre sujet pour continuer le BAFA
quatre lettres que l'on entend souvent
mais que se cache-t-il derrière le
brevet d'aptitude aux fonctions
d'animateur à la rencontre s'obtient ce
diplôme et quel est son contenu
théorique et pratique c'est ce que nous
avons voulu savoir en nous rendant cette
semaine à un stage BAFA à
Voisins-le-Bretonneux
dans un centre primaire en France
avec des enfants âges de 6 ans et plus
combien faut-il d'animateurs sachant
qu'ils sont vraiment au nombre de 60 OK
et la deuxième question
peut-on utiliser des masques
des tubas ou des palmes lors d'une
activité
nous ne sommes pas dans une salle de
classe mais au centre Alfred de Vigny de
voisins le bretonneuse
4 minutes et ceux qui sont autour des
tables ne sont pas en train de passer un
examen scolaire mais leur BAFA leur
brevet d'attitude aux fonctions
d'animateurs un diplôme qui leur
permettra ensuite de travailler en
centre de vacances ou de loisirs
d'autant plus demandé en ce moment que
les communes doivent organiser les tapes
les temps d'activité périscolaires au
sein des écoles le BAFA se décompose en
trois phases une première formation
générale de huit jours pour la porte
théorique de base
on va parler du public avec lequel les
stagiaires vont travailler donc les
enfants sachant que le BAFA vous permet
de travailler avec des mineurs de 3 ans
jusqu'à 17 ans donc là on a abordé la
connaissance de la petite enfance ainsi
que de l'enfance un peu de
pré-adolescence etc nous avons parlé de
tout ce qui est relations éducative
fournir des outils aux stagiaires pour
qu'ils puissent
savoir comment sanctionner qu'est ce
qu'une sanction comment savoir gérer des
situations au niveau relationnel pour
créer un relationnel de qualité avec les
enfants donc ça c'est plutôt sur la
partie torique en première partie de
stage ensuite on leur a transmis des
techniques d'animation après cette
formation théorique le BAFA se sont
également 14 jours de mise en pratique
sur le terrain et encore huit jours de
qualification sur des activités
spécifiques pour par exemple encadrer
des enfants à la piscine
après le cours théorique place au grand
jeu sarah est déjà animatrice vacataire
à la mairie de Guyancourt elle a fait le
choix de passer son BAFA pour se
perfectionner étudiante en licence
d'anglais elle se destine plus tard à
enseigner on apprend à organiser nos
idées par rapport à comment mener une
activité un jeu tout ça donc c'est on a
plus de d'organisation comme ça et pour
moi c'est en fait c'est une passion de
transmettre son savoir et
ce qu'on sait et puis on partage
beaucoup et c'est un public en fait qui
change tout le temps c'est pas quelque
chose de monotone pour devenir un bon
animateur il faut donc une certaine
technique mais surtout de la passion et
aimer les enfants sur cette semaine le
central Fred de Vigny a accueilli 23
stagiaires
le nom du successeur de Jacques Poron à
la tête du théâtre de 50 ans en Yvelines
vient d'être dévoilée il s'agit de
Lionel masetta actuel directeur de
Londres de Vélizy il a été désigné à la
fois par le ministère de la Culture et
le président de la Communauté
d'Agglomération de 50 ans Nîmes Lionel
Messi apprendra officiellement ses
fonctions en janvier 2015 un intérim est
actuellement mis en place après le
départ à la retraite de Jacques pour
nous survenu en octobre dans son projet
Lionel mazeta veut développer le théâtre
et la musique il souhaite aussi s'ouvrir
sur le territoire de l'agglomération est
plus largement du département associé
artiste mais également chercheurs
entreprises habitant à travers par
exemple des rencontres insité Lionel
masseta prend donc la suite de Jacques
porno ce dernier avait été nommé
directeur du Théâtre de la scène
nationale en septembre 2005 et aura donc
passé presque 10 ans à la tête du
théâtre de 50 ans en Yvelines et je vous
propose maintenant de passer à
l'essentiel de la semaine
la cour d'assise de Versailles a rendu
ce mercredi soir son verdict dans le
procès du policier de Mantes-la-Jolie
accusé de viol sur une femme alors
qu'elle était en cellule de dégrisement
le brigadier à écopé de 10 ans
le brigadier avait plaidé le malentendu
sexuel mais les jurés de la cour
d'assises de Versailles en ont jugé
autrement ils ont suivi les réquisitions
de l'avocat général et ont condamné
l'ancien policier de Mantes-la-Jolie à
10 ans de prison pour le viol le 6 mai
2012 d'une femme dans l'enceinte du
commissariat ce jour-là cette femme de
44 ans alcoolisée est emmenée par les
policiers pour être placés en cellule de
dégrisement elle aura une relation
sexuelle avec le brigadier en charge de
la Garde de Nuit ce dernier a assuré
qu'elle était consentante la victime
elle a parlé de cauchemars les jurés ont
donc tranché en estimant qu'il
s'agissait bien d'un viol commis par
personne abusant de l'autorité que lui
confère ses fonctions la peine prononcée
est une peine de 10 ans d'emprisonnement
et des dommages et intérêts ont été
alloués à ma cliente ainsi qu'à son mari
très soulagée que la culpabilité était
retenue
elle n'a pas fait de commentaires
particuliers sur la durée de la peine
d'emprisonnement c'est une peine qui est
importante évidemment ça reste un homme
qui n'a pas de casier judiciaire qui a
des enfants qui a un avenir donc c'est
une peine relativement lourde mais il
encourait quand même 20 ans
d'emprisonnement au départ on a un
dysfonctionnement au sein d'une
institution pour que finalement des
institutions interviennent comme elles
le devait l'avocat du policier n'était
pas joignable ce jeudi le policier
pourrait faire appel du jugement il a
jusqu'à mardi pour donner sa décision
cela fait plusieurs mois qu'au sein de
l'office HLM au pays vois il n'y a plus
de représentants ivinois et Vald voisien
alors que l'office est pourtant
intercommunal une situation qui agace le
nouveau président de l'opivoie mais
également le représentant des locataires
au sein du conseil d'administration
lui-même lui en courtois
lopie le premier bailleur
d'Île-de-France fonctionne depuis
maintenant deux ans avec un conseil
d'administration réduit en cause la
démission des élus des conseils généraux
des Yvelines et du Val-d'Oise seuls les
seuls à maintenu sa présence à l'époque
il souhaitait tirer la sonnette d'alarme
et alerté sur la gestion et la situation
financière de ce bailleur mais depuis la
situation n'a pas évolué ils n'ont pas
été remplacés une situation que déplore
les locataires les conseils du 95
garantissent plus les emprunts donc ça
fait que ça ça a bloqué des projets que
ça on a même certains projets abandonnés
comme un ville prolée clair comme une
certaine revitation mis du temps à se
mettre en place donc maintenant pierre
Badi nous dit qu'il y a d'autres
mécanismes financiers certes mais il est
présent du conseil général et avant
avant la mise en place d'autres
mécanismes c'est plutôt à lui en tant
que président à garantir l'empreinte du
deuxième bailleur de France les
administrateurs ont encore présents se
disent fragiliser un constat repris par
le nouveau président de l'op lors de sa
première conférence de presse en
septembre dernier oui moi j'ai été
frappé et heurté de voir des élus du
Conseil Général du 78 et du Conseil
Général du Val-d'Oise qui depuis deux
ans refuse de sier au conseil
d'administration de pivoie ils ont leur
place mais depuis deux ans ils n'ont pas
désigné leur représentance à thèse d'une
forme de désinvolture pour le président
du conseil général la solution réside
dans la départementalisation une fausse
bonne idée selon les administrateurs ce
changement de gestion accenturait les
écarts en termes de logement entre les
départements
très très inquiet au sein de l'opivoie
et ça veut dire quoi vis-à-vis de la
solidarité en Île-de-France c'est pour
ça que la religion est un est un projet
structurant la départementalisation a
pas de sens à l'échelle des des
économies qu'on pourrait faire la loi
alur permettrait à l'opivoie d'être
régionalisé d'ici 2016 des négociations
seraient actuellement en cours en
Île-de-France l'op ivoire regroupe 50
000 logements dont 16000 dans les
Yvelines
à l'occasion de la Journée mondiale de
lutte contre l'AVC ce mercredi le centre
hospice hospitalier de Versailles
organisé une journée de sensibilisation
l'accident vasculaire cérébral touche
une personne toutes les 5 secondes dans
le monde
un accident vasculaire cérébral c'est la
survenue d'un déficit brutal
neurologique où il existe une lésion
vasculaire dans 80% des cas il s'agit
d'un infarctus cérébral soit un caillot
dans une artère l'importance en cas
d'AVC c'est de réagir très rapidement
dans les 4h30 après la survenue des
premiers symptômes les signes les plus
caractéristiques en général ça survient
d'abord brutalement et c'est souvent
indolore ne fait pas consulter les gens
ça peut être des troubles de l'élocution
par exemple un patient il ne peut plus
sortir un mot ou un mot pour un autre ou
un jargon incompréhensible après il peut
y avoir des symptômes moteurs alors on
peut remarquer une déviation de la
bouche par exemple ou on tient on lâche
la fourchette tout simplement et ça ça
revient ou bien ça reste et puis on peut
avoir par exemple déficit de tout un
côté droit ou gauche dès l'apparition
des symptômes de pas hésiter à composer
le 15 impossible de prévenir un AVC il y
a 150 causes différentes parmi les
facteurs de risque le tabac l'alcool
l'hypertension ou encore le diabète max
sera mis a été victime de deux accidents
vasculaires cérébraux le premier en
février 2012 et le second en décembre
2013 le premier il m'a surpris même je
savais pas que c'était un AVC
le second je m'en suis pas rendu compte
puisque je venais d'être opéré et le
lendemain de mon opération j'ai fait la
vaisselle aujourd'hui après de nombreux
efforts de rééducation Max a pu
récupérer son bras gauche et poursuivre
la sculpture c'est grâce à la sculpture
un peu que j'ai repris maîtrise ma main
droite ça prouve quand même aux gens qui
viennent voir qu'on peut faire des
choses malgré un AVC c'est un message
d'espoir c'est tout et c'est ça pour les
orthophonistes que ce soit pour son
paralysés etc il faut travailler
jusqu'au point l'an passé 700 cas
d'aller ici ont été traités au centre
hospitalier de Versailles un nombre en
évolution constante
dans un des hangar de l'aérodrome de
Saint-Cyr-l'École Bertrand Gauthier un
passionné d'aéronautique fabrique
lui-même une réplique du chasseur
Mustang un avion mythique qui devrait
voler pour la première fois à la fin de
cette année
comme tous les jours Bernard Gauthier
part au travail mais son trajet est
plutôt très court car il a élu domicile
juste en face d'un hangar où il
construit la réplique d'un Mustang un
avion de chasse américain des années 40
donc là ça c'est la partie longeron
c'est la partie primordiale de de
l'avion parce que se fixe les trains se
fixe le vérin et puis c'est ce qui fait
la résistance cet ancien salarié d'Air
Inter aéré ses premiers boulons en 1992
avec par moment un arrêt du chantier
seulement pour construire lui-même sa
maison désormais Bernard Gauthier dans
la dernière ligne droite je pense qu'on
fait ça une seule fois dans sa vie on
fait ça une seule fois dans sa vie c'est
c'était un challenge son formation de
mécanicien il est incollable sur la
moindre pièce de son Mustang il a changé
le moteur et à installer un six
cylindres de 350 chevaux pour la
carlingue il a déniché du contreplaqué
et du titane pour de nombreuses rotules
il a d'ailleurs tout fabriqué lui-même à
l'exception de quelques comme le train
d'atterrissage ou encore le système
radio dans le cockpit l'objectif rester
fidèle à son illustre ancêtre j'ai
trouvé des vrais palonniers de Mustang
le manche de Mustang je veux absolument
la conception les banques tout ça
intérieurement tout ça c'est moi qui les
ai fait je veux ça ressemble à un avion
de guerre je veux pas de GPS je veux pas
de choses comme ça tous les instruments
c'est des vieux instruments qui sont
passés dans des commentaires des
professionnels qui les ont mis en état
ils sont tout neufs mais ce sont des
vieux instruments des manières plus les
choses comme ça extrêmement d'époque il
est même allé jusqu'à fabriquer des
répliques de mitrailleuses tout cela
pour un investissement total de 40000
euros à 64 ans Bernard Gautier ne compte
plus les heures passées dans ce hangar
son seul but voire voler son bébé et les
le premier décollage est prévu début
2015 mais avis aux intéressés il sera
très compliqué de prendre les commandes
je le dis tout de suite s'il y avait
quelqu'un qui pense qu'un jour s'asseoir
dedans statique nos problèmes le piloter
gros big problème
Gauthier et je vous propose maintenant
de découvrir une entreprise qui vient
juste de démarrer mais pourrait
rapporter beaucoup dans quelques années
car sa propriétaire installé à vie
cultive du safran une des épices les
plus chères au monde 30 000 euros le
kilo ça fait rêver
avec son panier en osier Aurélie Jacques
part à la cueillette non pas des
champignons c'est de saison mais du
safran une des épices les plus chères au
monde qui se cultivent en pleine terre
là vous avez la première parcelle que
j'ai planté l'année dernière
qui représente à peu près cette année
10000 bulles donc elle a déjà beaucoup
fleuri là on est en fin de récolte donc
il reste quelques fleurs les fleurs de
crocus sont cueillies le matin car elles
sortent la nuit elles sont ensuite
émondées pour isoler le pistil rouge qui
est la fameuse épice le pistil doit être
immédiatement séché une fois qu'il aura
perdu 80% de son poids il pourra être
mis en pot sur les parcours bien c'est
parti pour une demi-heure cette année
Aurélie Jacques accueillit 27000 fleurs
15000 bulbes supplémentaires ont été
plantés autant de plantations pour une
production de 300 g seulement de safran
et pour obtenir ces quelques grammes
beaucoup de travail on plante tout à la
main donc on est obligé de faire une
tranchée avec un outil qui s'appelle une
houe et après on plante à la main à
genoux on rebouche on fait les allées
avec une pelle donc déjà c'est assez
physique et après il y a le désherbage
qui se fait aussi à la main donc moi je
ne porte pas de pesticides et autres le
safran déjà que la découverte un peu par
hasard en 2008 ses parents agriculteurs
décident de prendre leur retraite se
posent la question de la reprise de
l'exploitation céréalière familiale un
voisin vient donner un coup de main
Aurélie imagine de créer elle-même ses
productions et apprend que le safran
pousse en France en 2012 j'ai fait un
stage de chez Veronique lazerac qui a la
plus grande safranière de France et puis
je me suis lancé dans l'aventure j'avais
fait un premier test en plantant mille
bulbes et en 2012 l'année dernière j'en
ai planté à peu près 5000 et puis cette
année j'en ai replanté 15000 de plus au
total la journée 25000 cette année la
culture du safran c'est loin loin de
l'univers d'Aurélie la jeune femme
travaille dans la finance pour une
société de gestion d'actifs toute une
organisation au moment de la récolte
comme il faut cueillir les fleurs le
matin j'y allais avant de travailler
donc j'y allais avec une lampe frontale
pour cueillir mes fleurs et puis après
j'allais travailler ma deuxième journée
à Paris
cette année Aurélie Jacques a vendu ses
premiers grammes de safran pour l'heure
c'est juste une diversification de
l'exploitation agricole mais à terme
pourquoi pas une vraie petite entreprise
qui pourrait s'annoncer très rentable
car le safran se monnaie 30 000 euros le
kilo il faut entre 150000 et 200000
fleurs pour en faire un kilo avec un
gramme de safran vous pouvez déjà
parfumer entre 50 et 150 assiettes un
gramme de safran vendu par Aurélie 34
euros en France il n'y a que 157
exploitations de safran pour une
production nationale qui est aussi entre
250 et 300 kg alors que l'île d'or eux
en Iran produisent entre 160 et 180
tonnes à l'année cela laisse donc
entrevoir de belles perspectives
économiques
et je vous en parlais en début de ce
journal l'agendarmerie des Yvelines
recherché un autre nager et bien plus de
peur que de mal cette personne âgée a
été retrouvée d'après nos confrères du
Parisien et c'était tout simplement
perdu cette édition du journal est
maintenant terminée merci de l'avoir
suivi l'information revient direct lundi
à 18h excellent weekend à vous